Yeah yeah yeah
[music]
car
go This time Broad's eyes might be wrung with sadness in his eyes The frog's eyes are open
I think it's cute when you see it
ja ah ah
I wonder if the pen is a marl image
This is my impression If you do it many times with that feeling you will be able to do it
good
wine
nhs tan
ah ah ah
me
car
4th re
4th place
tan
jun
ah ah ah
Meloron
believe it and eat it
I want to
definitely win the championship
we n
[Music]
The flowers are fast
, catch the ball on the crystal surface, Bach
The aim of such
a
rar  I know that Requiem is the love and sadness of a goddess
.
I just said the name of the play one more time,
then I'll start with my mouth.